je veux
t'emmener grimper 100 pieds dans les airs jusqu'au
sommet d'un séquoia
et je veux que tu viennes avec moi
et que tu
vois les écureuils sauter comme des
ballerines de branche en branche et
traiter un arbre que
je veux que tu vois  le brouillard
venant de l'océan et enveloppant la canopée
je veux que vous
entendiez l'appel de notre ami de l'
arbre suivant
qui dit qu'il veut venir
prendre un café il a juste besoin de se
tirer 50 mètres sur une
corde horizontale  pour y arriver
c'est à quoi ressemble la vie dans les arbres
nous avons une série de cordes interconnectées
et
nous
faisons tout là-haut
les animaux vous traitent comme si vous n'étiez
même pas un humain vous ressemblez plus à l'un d'
eux
et tellement  de sorte que la première fois que
j'ai grimpé dans un arbre,
il y a trois chouettes tachetées qui
m'ont suivi tout le chemin en me regardant
avec leurs yeux
et quelques nuits plus tard, je me suis réveillé et
il y avait un écureuil qui me câlinait dans
mon sac de couchage
et je  vient de
se retourner et de revenir t  o dormir et
quand je me suis réveillé le matin,
le couvercle de mon seau a été soulevé
au milieu de la nuit et il y a eu
trois bouchées de tout ce que
j'avais,
ils sont très espiègles,
c'est une chose très exigeante physiquement
d'être debout  dans les arbres, vous devez
être très intentionnel, vous devez
vraiment bouger comme un écureuil
et
vous devez exister en trois dimensions
au lieu de deux comme nous sommes dans le
monde terrestre et vous utilisez vraiment chaque muscle de
votre corps et
chaque
once de  concentration que vous devez
faire les choses les plus simples comme faire une
tasse de thé
ou préparer votre lit pour aller dormir
et beaucoup de gens
demandent avez-vous peur avez-vous peur de tomber
et je pense que la réponse est que
tant de force est  dans ces arbres et
quand vous êtes là sur les branches, vous vous
sentez plus en sécurité que partout ailleurs dans
le monde,
ils vous retiennent littéralement
et le temps qui passe est
absolument époustouflant là-bas, vous
pouvez passer cinq minutes et ça  ça fait
cinq heures ou on peut passer toute la
journée et il fait sombre comme ça donc
c'est un endroit très mystérieux
où on ne peut même pas
vraiment sentir le temps qui passe comme quand
on est en ville
donc je veux diriger  dans quelques faits sur les
séquoias et cela pourrait vous aider à
comprendre pourquoi ils sont si importants pour
moi.
Tout d'abord, il y a l'
un des organismes les plus anciens sur
la face de la planète, ils peuvent vivre
plus de 2 000 ans et ils peuvent atteindre
plus de  10 pieds de diamètre,
ce sont aussi les organismes vivants les plus hauts
de la planète et
c'est vraiment incroyable quand on y
pense parce que
notre technologie humaine nous a seulement la
capacité de pomper de l'eau verticalement jusqu'à un
gradient vertical
aussi haut que  33 pieds, mais les séquoias peuvent le
faire jusqu'à 370 pieds, soit plus de
10 fois la quantité que notre propre
technologie peut faire
et ils sont également le meilleur
écosystème de la planète pour
séquestrer le dioxyde de carbone de l'
atmosphère non seulement ils  séquestrent
le plus de co2 par hectare,
ils accélèrent et accélèrent également leur
taux de stockage à mesure qu'ils vieillissent, ce qui
signifie que les forêts anciennes et les forêts matures en
attente de devenir anciennes sont
les écosystèmes les plus
précieux
que nous pourrions éventuellement
protéger afin de nous défendre
contre les pires effets du changement climatique,
on pourrait penser que tout cela serait
automatiquement protégé,
ce n'est tout simplement pas le cas, il y a des
millions d'acres de forêt de séquoias
ainsi que
des épinettes à fourrure de doug de divers types qui sont
entre les mains d'entreprises forestières privées
et  leur objectif est de transformer ces
arbres en bois à vendre
et je pense que nous avons besoin d'un sérieux
changement dans nos priorités, nous devons
décider
s'il est plus important pour nous d'avoir du
bois ou s'il est plus important pour nous d'avoir
une planète vivable parce que
chaque fois  nous abattons ces arbres, nous
libérons finalement ce co2 dans
l'atmosphère et bien sûr si nous
préservons
ces forêts, elles sont ar  e vraiment
un puits de carbone incommensurablement merveilleux pour
la planète entière
et donc j'apporte en quelque sorte
la question de savoir qui voulons-nous un
profit privé ou des biens communs publics et c'est une
très
grande raison pour laquelle la forêt est si importante
pour moi
et
j'ai trouvé à travers  mon expérience qu'il
n'y a vraiment aucun autre recours que les
gens ont pour protéger ces terres autres
que de mettre leur corps en danger
parce qu'il n'y a tout simplement aucun système
mis en
place pour faire quoi que ce soit dans le cadre du
système juridique à ce sujet, donc les gens n'ont vraiment pas d'autre
choix quand ils  voir les écosystèmes
qu'ils aiment être détruits plutôt que de
grimper là-haut et de mettre leur corps en jeu
et d'empêcher physiquement la destruction de se
produire,
cela vient de Berkeley Tree sit en 2008.
donc pour revenir à cette même idée,
je veux entrer dans un exemple  de la façon dont
l'action directe a été couronnée de succès
il y a plusieurs années,
il s'agit d'une zone appelée le tractus mckay
qui est situé dans le comté de humboldt en
californie,
c'est
le meilleur au monde  Pour faire pousser des séquoias,
il n'y a nulle part ailleurs que plus d'entre eux
poussent ou plus rapidement que ces 7000
acres ici
et l'un des bosquets les plus matures et les plus développés
de cette région devait être coupé
par une entreprise forestière et à sa place,
ils voulaient  construire un lotissement
et quelques amis à moi et moi sommes allés là-
bas et quand nous sommes entrés dans cette forêt
qui allait être abattue, la première
chose que nous avons vue
était deux chouettes tachetées qui faisaient
leur rituel d'accouplement et c'était vraiment
génial à voir  c'était comme un signe pour nous,
cela disait que cette forêt est
spéciale c'est un endroit où nous devons
vraiment nous enfoncer et nous engager et mettre
nos corps en jeu afin de la
défendre
et c'est donc ce que nous avons fait nous
avons  un arc et une flèche ont tiré une ligne dans l'
arbre et nous avons grimpé de plus de 100 pieds dans
la canopée du séquoia et nous avons fait une promesse
et un engagement à y rester jusqu'à ce que
ces arbres soient protégés,
beaucoup de gens ont dit oh ça n'arrivera jamais
oh la société  veut juste faire un
profit, ils ne vont pas vous écouter les
gars, vous êtes un groupe trop petit pour
vraiment faire quoi que ce soit à ce sujet,
mais
le mot s'est répandu, les gens sont venus de
tout le pays du monde entier
et nous ont aidés à reconstituer  attachez ces
arbres ensemble et construisez un vaste
village qui s'étendait sur 55 arbres
et plusieurs acres et plusieurs peuplements
d'arbres c'était un village d'arbres littéral
où vous pouviez aller d'un bout
à l'autre du bosquet sans jamais vous arrêter
au même  arbre c'était comme une boucle géante que
vous pouviez continuer à grimper pendant des jours
et c'est l'une des expériences les plus spéciales
que j'ai jamais eues pour pouvoir
vivre là-haut et être acceptée par les
hiboux et les écureuils en tant que membre
du  canopée,
donc l'action directe fonctionne vraiment et c'est
une chose importante qui aide à
faire pression sur les entreprises de
bas en haut et c'est quelque chose
que nous
devons vraiment faire beaucoup plus
parce que
nous avons très peu de temps pour
gérer les s  certains problèmes graves, principalement
le changement climatique mondial, et je ne vois
aucune solution réelle venant du
niveau institutionnel et je ne vois aucun
progrès majeur réalisé, ce qui me porte
à croire que le seul
recours dont nous disposons en tant que citoyens du
monde est  intervenir et mettre nos corps
en jeu pour défendre les endroits que nous
aimons où que ce soit pour nous
et
c'est différent pour tout le monde je pense
que nous devrions tous faire ça
partout
donc nous avons gagné ça marche parfois et quand ça
ne marche pas
nous sommes toujours en train de
préparer le terrain pour que les prochaines personnes arrivent
et s'assurent une vraie victoire, donc
c'est une sorte de belle chose qui
ouvre un monde de possibilités et
vous savez quand vous vous engagez dans le système
et que vous partez  grâce à des méthodes légales, vous pouvez
toujours presque mesurer exactement le type
de résultat que vous allez obtenir, mais avec
une action directe, vous appuyez en quelque sorte sur le
bouton de réinitialisation de l'histoire et vous
ouvrez le monde à une toute
nouvelle gamme de possibilités  et vous ne saurez peut-être
jamais où se situent
les conséquences de vos actions
, car les
gens peuvent être inspirés par une seule
action. Par exemple, en
1985,
un homme nommé Mike a grimpé sur un arbre à fourrure doug
dans l'Oregon et il est devenu le premier vrai
gardien d'Amérique du Nord.
aucune idée qu'il allait
inspirer un mouvement de
milliers de personnes sur une période de
30 ans qui sortiraient dans la
forêt et risqueraient leur vie pour
faire la même chose que lui,
ce n'est qu'un exemple
du pouvoir  d'une seule personne pour inspirer
tout un mouvement de personnes et aujourd'hui d'
uniston à santa cruz il y a des centaines
de personnes qui travaillent activement à la
défense de la forêt par l'
action directe et font pression sur le
système de bas en haut
nous avons gagné
je veux partir  vous avec cette citation
c'est de gandhi et je pense qu'il a vraiment
beaucoup de choses à droite,
il dit ne doutez jamais qu'un petit corps d'
esprits déterminés tirés par une
foi inextinguible en leur mission  peut
modifier le cours de l'histoire
et je veux vous inviter
dès maintenant à imaginer un endroit
qui signifie le monde pour vous que votre
cœur se briserait si quelque chose lui
arrivait et je veux que vous y alliez la
prochaine fois que vous avez une chance
et je  je veux que vous fermiez les yeux et que vous vous
connectiez à cet endroit
et que vous imaginiez à quoi ressemblera cet endroit
dans 50 ans et 100 ans
, puis je veux que vous imaginiez ce que vous
voulez voir quel avenir vous
désirez vraiment
et puis je  Je veux que nous mettions tous
nos compétences, nos talents, notre passion et nos
ressources pour faire en sorte que cet endroit
continue le plus longtemps possible et
c'est l'espoir d'une action directe,
il
y a
le pouvoir de l'amour de pouvoir
changer
le cœur des gens et pouvoir
littéralement changer le cours de l'histoire
et faire quelque chose que les gens
vous diront est impossible
c'est ce que c'est
vous